thanks to curiosity stream for keeping
legal eagle in the air get 40% off of
curiosity stream and nebula with a link
in the description at the moment there
is no cure or treatment for köppen 19
but that hasn't stopped some of the
world's prominent experts from claiming
to have found a cure rodney
howard-browne said if they sneeze it it
shoots up down like at a hundred miles
an hour a little you know neutralize it
in split seconds President Trump said a
lot of people think that goes away in
April with the heat as the heat comes in
typically that will go away at April
commissioner Culpepper said is the sound
really goofy and it did to me too but it
works so you hold a blow-dryer in front
of your face and you inhale with your
nose and it kills all the viruses in
your nose and Kenneth Copeland said and
President Trump also said right and then
I see the disinfectant and is there way
we can do something like that by
injection inside etc now some of these
clips are funny but they're also
infuriating people who promote snake oil
cures Tecopa 19 prey on the sick and the
vulnerable a suggestion may seem
harmless but encouraging people to buy
or take concoctions that don't actually
work can cause lasting damage
you may be wondering whether these
people have legal liability for
promoting these fake coronavirus cures
you've probably seen them on Facebook
from well-intentioned ants and debated
them in the comments section of your
local news station but let's talk about
what consequences these people actually
face and oh yes we are definitely going
to talk about the president's question
about injecting bleach and taking
sunlight internally
[Music]
hey legal eagles it's time to think like
a lawyer because there's a lot of bad
information out there and you may be
thinking that when people lie
intentionally they face stiff legal
consequences but it's important to note
that in the status quo the default
position is that you don't face
liability for free speech that's what
the First Amendment is all about and as
we've covered many times on this channel
there generally is no criminal or civil
liability for lying
generally speaking the First Amendment
exists for a reason and I personally
think that that's a good thing generally
you're not going to be sued for making
false statements even potentially false
statements about cures and treatments
even if you post them to Facebook or
YouTube and your comments are viewed by
millions of people because that's what
free speech is about free speech covers
even bad ideas and false ones and it's a
problem because the less people know
about these complicated subjects the
more confident they are which is why
today's video is sponsored by Dunning
Kruger if you're like me you know more
about managing critically ill patients
than doctors and scientists who've
dedicated their entire careers to it and
so you should drink dunning-kruger it's
the only choice for the self educated
gentleman Dunning Kruger it'll give you
confidence although I don't think you
need any help with that Cheers
however there are times when you go
beyond that and especially when you're
selling products and you're making
specific claims about what this product
can and cannot do there are times when
you might face civil or sometimes even
criminal liability so let's talk about
things that are clearly criminal under
18 USC 1347 it is a crime to commit
health care fraud regarding providers
and many people promote cures and
treatments for Coppa 19 online so when
does this cross the line well the DOJ
recently filed its first legal action
for coronavirus related fraud under the
statute for a website that promised to
give people World Health Organization
vaccine kits in exchange for a shipping
charge of 495 now I can be fairly
certain that these allegations give rise
to fraud if true because there isn't a
vaccine for kovat 19 so
when you try and bilk medical providers
out of money for something that isn't
true
that's health care fraud and then
there's the old-fashioned kind of fraud
where you knowingly lie to people to get
their money there's the potential case
of the people who promote garlic and
honey as a cure for coronavirus some
even link to a journal article that
purports to provide evidence for staking
one's life on the garlic cure
now the NIH Journal article that these
people cite sue merely finds that garlic
extract had inhibitory effects on
bronchitis and when tested on chicken
embryos which is not the same as working
on people and despite the pseudo
scientific basis for their claims these
people generally haven't committed fraud
because it's not illegal necessarily to
spread false information but it is
illegal to sell pills or cures or
products that are harmful or have no
real benefit or are based on real things
when you make those kind of claims but
I'm just a lawyer what do I know
hey dr. Frances honey and garlic
actually cure coronavirus honey and
garlic have not been shown to be
effective in the treatment of
coronavirus they have however been shown
to be more delicious than placebo in
seven out of ten
chicken marinades well even if these
people aren't put in jail hopefully
they'll get their just desserts
now that's fraud but there are other
causes of action that can attach in
circumstances like these like negligent
misrepresentation in some cases
liability doesn't require in knowing
falsehoods like fraud does negligent
misrepresentation differs from fraud
because it doesn't require showing a
malicious intent or recklessness by the
defendant instead it just requires that
a defendant's statement be exaggerated
or misstate certain facts and that these
miss statements resulted from the
defendants negligence or lack of due
diligence but it also has to occur in a
circumstance that gives rise to a duty
between the two parties so again simply
going around the world saying
misstatements even based on negligence
doesn't necessarily make you liable for
negligent misrepresentation because you
have to be in a relationship with the
people that are harmed and rely on those
statements no I think our discussion of
negligent misrepresentation should
probably start with the most powerful
person in the United States president
Trump because the president loves to
talk about chloroquine and it's
derivative hydroxychloroquine as a
potential miracle cure for a cove at 19
the drugs are already approved for use
to treat lupus and rheumatoid arthritis
and preliminary research has suggested
that the medications could be and I
stress could be here helpful in treating
kovin 19 well the President and Fox News
have repeatedly touted one small French
study of twenty patients that followed
the patients for six days it's currently
being prescribed in France for at least
one studies suggests that it works three
of those 20 patients ended up in the ICU
one left the hospital one couldn't
tolerate the medication and one died but
again I defer to the experts here hey
dr. Francis is hydroxychloroquine a
miracle cure the simple answer is we
just don't know it may be it may not it
has shown some promise in in vitro
studies meaning in a laboratory not in
humans but at the time of recording
there are no trials convincingly showing
evidence of its efficacy the French
study that got so much attention which
was non randomized has many many
problems
chief being the differential loss to
follow-up from the treatment arm that
you were just hearing about however does
that mean we need to just ignore its
findings entirely of course not
does it provide enough evidence to start
treating everybody with the
hydroxychloroquine definitely not does
it provide enough evidence to want to
undertake further research absolutely
and there are many trials ongoing all
over the world
the w-h-o is launching a huge multi
Center multi national trial looking at
the hydroxychloroquine and already in
many hospitals all over America and
other countries hydroxychloroquine is
being given routinely now that's partly
because we have few other options but it
is being used however all of that has to
be in the context of a clinical trial
otherwise you just don't know what
you're doing you're not going to assess
the response
remember 99% of people that get this or
war do not die so to tease out the
effects of any treatment is going to be
complicated we need answers to questions
like if it is effective in whom is it
most effective in the sickest patients
in intensive care or is it better for
prophylaxis
we're potentially talking about millions
of people here so we need solid evidence
yeah science is hard but the president
said that he would make the drug
available almost immediately and a day
later President Trump tweeted
hydroxychloroquine in azithromycin taken
together have a real chance to be one of
the biggest game changers in the history
of medicine
the FDA has moved mountains thank you
president Trump has said the drugs are
safe and the patients have nothing to
lose by taking them nice pot is it's
been around for a long time
so we know that if it if if things don't
go as planned it's not going to kill
anybody
hey dr. Francis do people have nothing
to lose by taking a medication that's
been around for a while
hydroxychloroquine an azithromycin have
indeed been around a long time and so we
do know about their side-effects and
both of them can cause a side effect
called long QT which is where the
electrics of your heart can be affected
increasing your risk of suffering a
potentially fatal cardiac arrest now we
don't see this complication very often
in patients taking hydroxychloroquine
for conditions like lupus which is one
of its common uses so that may lead you
to conclude that it's safe in all
settings but remember these patients are
being closely monitored by their doctors
but more importantly they're a totally
different patient population took over
19 kovat sufferers are much more on well
they have high rates of cardiac and
kidney involvement which could hugely
increase their risk so what happens if
people rely on these statements and then
get sick or die well unfortunately we
have the answer in Arizona man died and
his wife was hospitalized after they
took chloroquine phosphate in an attempt
to avoid getting coded 19 although
neither had any symptoms of the virus
they've been listening to President
Trump in his allies promote this quote
cure tremendous breakthrough the woman
explained that she noticed she had some
fish tank cleaner and that one of the
ingredients was chloroquine she said and
her advice now oh my god don't take
anything
don't believe anything are you doctor
now I've covered presidential immunity
in my prior video about suing China or
the president so this couple is not
going to be recovering anything for the
president anytime soon but even if that
weren't the case the president refrained
from making any unqualified factual
statements about the drug and of course
he wasn't selling this drug and he
wasn't in a position that gave rise to a
duty of care to the American people well
at least not a legal position that gives
rise to legal liability and recently
there's been a lot of literature coming
out that hydroxychloroquine is likely
not a miracle cure and net-net may lead
to many negative health consequences
which is perhaps why President Trump has
turned to other potential cures right
and then I see the disinfectant it
knocks it out in a minute
one minute and is there way we can do
something like that by injection inside
or almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number along so it'd be
interesting to check that so that you're
gonna have to use medical doctors with
but it sounds it sounds interesting to
me I have a lot of thoughts about this
so many thoughts now I'll talk more
about those thoughts at the end of this
video now one of the defenses that
people have raised about the president's
remarks is that he was only raising the
question about injecting bleach not
actually suggesting that people do that
now believe it or not that actually
parallels a discussion in the legal
community about hearsay recall that
hearsay is an out-of-court statement
used to prove the truth of the matter
asserted key phrases there being
statement and the matter asserted then
the question is a question is a question
a statement is a question actually
promoting some sort of assertion I think
most people probably believe that a
question can in fact be a statement for
purposes of hearsay because there's
often a premise behind that and with the
president's remarks there is the premise
behind that question the premise being
that people should in fact consume
bleach internally don't do that
but as with the president's remarks
about hydroxychloroquine liability
probably wouldn't attach to the press
remarks about ingesting bleach or
internally consuming sunlight in some
way and that result doesn't change
whether the person talking about
ingesting bleach is a random person off
the street or if it's the President of
the United States even if there was in
fact apparently a spike in people
ingesting disinfectants following the
president's remarks now the obvious
point here is that no one should be
swallowing fish tank cleaner or
injecting bleach regardless of what the
president says thinking critically when
you're listening to cable news or the
president regardless of who is in the
White House is probably always a good
idea but what else could in fact give
rise to criminal or civil penalties
federal mail and wire fraud statutes are
interpreted broadly to prescribe one
causing the use of the mail or wire
communications including email to in
conjunction with a scheme to
intentionally defraud another of money
or property 3 by means of a material
deception wire and mail fraud are crimes
on their own but they also overlap with
a lot of other federal statutes people
get confused that often the same
conducts can give rise to a lot of
different crimes based on on the various
things and it's the exact same conduct
essentially if you use the mail
telephone or Internet to defraud people
if you can also be charged with mail and
wire fraud even though it probably
constitutes regular fraud in a lot of
different contexts in fact the New York
Times just reported that a doctor in
Southern California was accused of fraud
for selling a cure to corona virus which
turned out to be hydroxychloroquine and
as a thorough myocin but the DOJ is
pursuing a lot of kovat 19 fraudsters
using these criminal statutes for
example Keith Middlebrook an actor with
an uncredited appearance in Iron Man 2
and Thor was arrested by the FBI for
soliciting investments into a company he
said would market phony kovat 19
medication Middlebrook promised
investors who spent a million dollars
returns of two hundred to three hundred
million dollars as a conservative
minimum Middlebrook promoted his scheme
on Instagram where he had 2.4 million
followers and was charged with wire
fraud the lesson here don't take medical
advice from non-medical professionals
even if they were in a Marvel movie and
also sometimes don't trust even the
medical professionals who promote a cure
that doesn't yet
exist but that was probably a good time
to talk about the difference between
false advertising and puffery because a
lot of people say that they'll see an ad
and they'll think that it's completely
fraudulent but advertisers have a lot of
leeway because again we generally don't
want to prosecute people for just saying
ideas or having opinions and one of the
big issues in this context is objective
factual statements which are false
compared to subjective opinion based
statements people who are selling
products have a right to talk them up
and even embellish how great they are
however the government has the power to
stop companies for making claims that
are objectively false or factual claims
without basis so let's choose an example
at random look one of those random
late-night infomercials featuring I
don't know my pillow hello i'm michael
adele adventure of my pillow this is a
classic example of both potentially
false advertising and puffery the sort
of building up of a product that doesn't
constitute actionable statements puffery
consists of general descriptions such as
top quality best or America's favorite
so Michael Lyndell creator of my pillow
and pal of President Trump has filmed
many infomercials where he says his
pillow will ensure you get the best
sleep of your life now this example has
nothing to do with the fact that
President Trump hosted this guy in the
Rose Garden but the statement is likely
just puffery no one can truly prove that
$40 my pillow is gonna be better than
the pillow that you buy at Big Lots for
5 dollars it's a largely subjective
statement but our friend Mike Lyndell
also ran into problems with consumer
protection advocates when he made
specific health claims about my pillow
lindell's many advertisements asserted
that the pillow could help people manage
migraines anxiety multiple sclerosis
PTSD restless leg syndrome
acid reflux disease fibromyalgia snoring
and many other medical conditions hey
dr. Frances can a pillow cure any of
those ailments no it cannot cure those
elements look just use a pillow for the
same reason everybody else does
companionship yeah so a consumer
protection group sued Lyndell for false
advertising and although Lyndell claimed
no wrongdoing he settled the case for
almost a million dollars and removed the
assertions that my pillow would help
with
of those diseases so what are the most
common ways to get sued for false
statements and bad products well the
most common is probably consumer fraud
people who make false or misleading
product claims face legal action for
both government authorities and private
consumers and although people on the
internet often say this is the kind of
thing that should give rise to a class
action and we're gonna have a class
action to sue China or President Trump
this context in the consumer protection
environment is the kind of thing that
often gives rise to class action
lawsuits and several companies are in
hot water over outlandish claims that
they made that they can cure coronavirus
take natural health expert Sheryl Selman
she appeared on television last June
Baker's television show to sell the
silver solution a cure for kovat 19
supposedly well let's say it hasn't been
tested on this strain of the corona
virus but it's been tested on other
stranger on of the corona virus and has
been able to eliminate it within 12
hours and she made claims that the
silver solution has been proven by the
government that it has the ability to
kill every pathogen it has ever been
tested on including SARS and HIV Jim
Baker then holds up the product and
suggests viewers pay eighty to one
hundred twenty-five dollars to the show
in exchange for a bottle of silver
solutions the solution is a form of
collodial silver a liquid supplement
that contains very tiny pieces of silver
and not surprising ingesting silver can
actually be quite dangerous here's a
photo of someone who took silver nosed
droplets for years hey dr. Frances can
silver cure every disease known to man
no it won't but even if it did I mean
sulfuric acid killed a lot of microbes
I wouldn't recommend taking that either
yeah so this is potentially a very
clear-cut case of consumer fraud and the
DOJ in several states have actually sent
Baker's cease and desist orders for
falsely promoting that silver solution
can cure kill or deactivate corona virus
and boost elderly consumers immune
systems when there is in fact no vaccine
no pill or potion or other product that
can treat or cure corona virus and
similarly state and federal regulators
have also moved to stop radio host a
noted idiot Alex Jones from selling fake
cures including a toothpaste that
contains nano silver the
did nano silver we have the Pentagon has
come out and documented and Homeland
Security had said this stuff kills the
whole czars coronal at point-blank range
well of course it does it kills every
virus and after the inevitable cease and
desist letters Jones issued a disclaimer
where he walked back a lot of his claims
however the videos of these products are
still up so Jones may not be out of hot
water but this is a situation that he
finds himself in with some frequency now
is the time to get ready and to get
prepared with emergency supplies and
items that are known to boost your
immune system now also there are causes
of action for things called unfair
business practices which overlap often
with fraud but are not exactly the same
state and federal laws allow a business
to be sued for unfair and deceptive
trade practices the phrase unfair trade
practice means any business practice or
acts that is deceptive fraudulent or
causes injury to a consumer so for
example a Florida elected official of
course Florida
Brian Culpepper claim that you can kill
cope at 19 by aiming your hair dryer up
your nose so you hold a blow to air in
front of your face and you inhale with
your nose and it kills all the viruses
in your nose huh
hey dr. Frances there's a hair dryer
kill the coronavirus yeah so incredibly
dumb information because of course
elected official in Florida but can he
be sued well probably not like I said
before it's not illegal to say something
dumb or false and Culpepper is giving
out bad information but he's not selling
a product like a special kovat 19
killing hairdryer he's just a Floridian
never change Florida man never change
but it can be hard to get the word out
on YouTube when we're dealing with
sensitive subjects because videos like
these get demonetized but some people
need to be told not to inject themselves
with bleach namely the entire state of
Florida which is why my Creator friends
and I teamed up to build our own
platform where creators don't need to
worry about D monetization or the
dreaded algorithm it's called nebula and
we're thrilled to be partnering with
curiosity stream nebula is a place where
creators can do what we do best create
it's a place where we can both house our
content add free and also experiment
with original content and new series
that probably wouldn't work
on YouTube in fact if you liked this
episode the version that I put up on
nebula removes this ad entirely and
replaces it with an extended discussion
of president Trump's Bleach comments I
don't want to get off on a rant here but
I am going to anyway nebula features
lots of YouTube's top educational
creators like half is interesting
knowing better polyphonic Lindsey Ellis
and tons of others we also get to
collaborate in ways that wouldn't work
on YouTube like Tom Scott's amazing game
show money where he puts a bunch of
famous youtubers against each other in
psychological experiments where they can
either work together or profit
individually it is so so good so does
this have to do with curiosity stream
well as the go-to source for the best
documentaries on the Internet they love
educational content and educational
creators and we've worked out a deal
where if you sign up for curiosity
stream with a link in the description
not only will you get one free month of
curiosity stream you'll also get a
nebula subscription for free and to be
clear that nebula subscription is not a
trial it's free for as long as you are
curiosities to remember and for a
limited time
curiosity stream is offering their
documentary distancing discount which
gives you 40% off of their annual plans
and gift cards so you can stay in touch
and stay curious
that's $12 a year for both curiosity
stream and nebula for as long as you are
a member and since we've got to stay
inside anyway we might as well be
soothed by the voice of David
Attenborough narrating tales about tiny
hummingbirds or join astronaut Chris
Haddonfield on a road trip through the
universe and some of the best
documentaries on the planet or just
watch Tom Scott torture your favorite
youtubers so if you click on the link in
the description you'll get both
curiosity stream and nebula for 40% off
or you can go to curiosity stream comm
slash legal eagle it's a great way to
support this channel and educational
content directly for just $12 per year
just click on the link in the
description or go to curiosity stream
comm slash legal eagle clicking on the
link really helps out this channel so do
you agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here with all of my
other real law reviews on coronavirus
related topics so click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court